[Music]
welcome back to another episode of
what's up prof hi martin hello alta
i'm doing well uh i never even asked you
but you are very forthcoming i'm happy
to hear it and what about you
i'm happy to hear it
so let's open with the word of prayer
our heavenly father thank you for
bringing us together again we ask that
you please
help us through this discussion
and enlighten our minds thank you for
everything in jesus name amen
amen
martin
the questions
are always there
so
let's see what we can do with them
so i i'll read the questions for you and
then oh that's kind of your mod then i
can we can
initiate a dialogue here okay this
person asked i would love to hear from
the what the two watchmen their
perspective on what this verse in luke
means so luke 21 36 says watch ye
therefore and pray always
that he may be accounted worthy to
escape all these things that shall come
to pass and to stand before the son of
man
all right luke 21 is the
mirror image of matthew 24. that's it
so it's about the signs of the times
now we can have a long discussion on
this issue
i'm very happy
that
the
the questioner
refers to us as two watchmen
watchmen what of the night yes
all right and we that is exactly what
like we've mentioned in the previous
episode
that's what we want to be questions on
the wall so what can we glean from this
verse this this verse is actually very
significant
it starts with what ye therefore
is it a request or is it a command yes
come on
it is a command
now
watching will it save you no
can it put you in the right frame of
mind yes ah and then there has to come
become an action all right so people can
become
addicted to watching for signs
and there will be many that will label
such people conspiracy theorists right
but it is a condition that the lord says
now
when you just stick with this word watch
what must you watch for
well obviously it will that part will
also be
said in the in the word okay so you must
watch for those signs
which the lord has given as to the
closeness of his coming
now can that influence your relationship
with god yes for sure
can it uh move someone who is totally
agnostic
to becoming a believer again
definitely because you can see how that
that was predicted
comes true
all right so watching
is not a request
it's a command but it's coupled to
something
pray always
so the watching is coupled to prayer
now prayer is a personal communication
between you and god
so if you pray to someone
does that mean you have a relationship
yes
that's talking to him all right so
watching and prayer when they are linked
together
it means that you have a relationship
but the relationship has actually
progressed to the point of trust
faith
exactly so when you see the signs
your faith is actually strengthened
because without faith it is impossible
to please him
so watching
linked to prayer
means that you have a living
relationship with christ
then you follow with the rest that you
may be accounted worthy to escape all
these things that shall come to pass
that can also be misinterpreted this
part all right so
people say okay if you're watching then
you will be counted worthy no no no if
you have this relationship
[Music]
and it grows and your faith grows and
your trust grows
and in the end
when you watch the signs you must also
realize your hopeless position
exactly and the more the signs are being
fulfilled
the more you must be pushed in the
direction of christ
and if you are covered by the
righteousness of christ then you will be
accounted worthy to escape all the
things that come to pass
because only those that have the white
robe of righteousness
will be counted worthy you must look at
the parallel texts
without the robe buy from me gold
refined in the fire
and a robe
you need a robe that is
washed
in the blood of the lamb
so you need the righteousness of christ
and then you'll be able to stand before
the son of man
what happens to those that are not
clothed with the righteousness of christ
they will not be able to stand
they will be destroyed by the brightness
of his coming right
so the other thing also that i can see
maybe there can be some confusion in
this is that worthy to escape all things
people might perceive that they will not
have to go through anything in the end
no
because
we have to enter heaven through much
tribulation
and if we look at type and anti-type
the hebrews
were very much
in the world when the plagues fell
that was the type so the anti-type the
anti-typical
israel will also be in the world when
the plagues fall
so we will be here in the time of
trouble
but whether we stand or
fail it depends on our relationship with
christ and depends on whether we have
appropriated the righteousness of christ
you will not be part of the annihilation
of the world yes but it will often seem
as though you will be engulfed by it
but the lord will have a people that
will be translated
elijah is the guarantor
of that
because he was translated without seeing
death and he's the representative of
those that will be translated at the end
without seeing death
so martin
watching
the signs of the times is often
criticized in the world today
it's called fear-mongering
but it is a a condition
and you have to be a watchman
now what do we do when we record
what's up profs and we look at the signs
of the times we are watching
we are watching to see if the things
predicted in the bible are coming to
fruition
putting it all into perspective all
right now what about those that
criticize it
there's a verse in the bible
matthew 24 verse 48
but and if that evil servant shall say
in his heart the lord delayeth his
coming
and he shall begin to smite his fellow
servants and eat and drink with the
drunken
the lord of that servant will come in
that day when he looketh not for him
and in an hour that he is not aware of
jesus said
through his representatives
that we are not in darkness that that
day should overtake us
right we should know
now how can we know
if we watch watch
exactly so you're linking it right
now
this evil servant
he's a servant
so he's
falling under
the people that's actually watching all
right he's got god's servants he is in
the church
but he's an evil servant
and he is saying my lord delaith is
coming why would he say that
because he's not watching the signs
and if you watch the signs you will say
well the coming of the lord is coming
closer so the evil servant is one that
does not watch for the signs and he's
constantly criticizing those that watch
for the signs and writing their little
articles in their little magazines
criticizing those that watch for the
signs of the times do we have them in
the church yes
and they are also probably
not ready
for this all right so should we become
discouraged because they are in the
church
even if they are in leadership position
no because we have our marching orders
watch watch
those are higher marching orders than
those that say stop watching exactly
it's nicely put
okay
so what are these
servants that do not watch
and that say that this is fear-mongering
what will they start doing eventually if
you keep on watching
smite you they will start smiting their
fellow servants
why would they smite them martin
because they don't want to hear this
machine why don't they want to hear it
because they are eating and drinking
with a drunken that's it
now who are the drunken martin
those that are drunk with the wine of
babylon ah so they are sitting in
ecumenical councils and are beginning to
see things in the same light as those
that are drunk with the wine of babylon
and they probably think
that keeping sunday for the sake of
climate change is a pretty good idea
because the planet is in dire straits in
terms of climate change
that's exactly they've never heard of
harp they've never heard of chemtrails
they've never heard of any of these
things these are all conspiracy theories
so they start thinking like the world
because they are sitting at the same
table with those
that have drunken from the wine of
babylon
and therefore because
keeping the sunday will save a little
bit of gasoline and end some pollution
seems a pretty logical thing to do so
how can you possibly even think that
that is a religious law it's a purely
secular law it's fine to do it
i think they're not watching nope
they're not watching and all the signs
that we show
of this happening
is merely conspiracy conspiracy
all right so what will the lord do with
that servant so the lord of that servant
shall come in a day when he looketh not
for him
why does he not look for him he wasn't
watching
he's been going round and round
he's not watching
he's sitting at the table drinking with
those that are drunk with the wine of
babylon and who is actually saying that
lord's
is delaying his coming so he's agreeing
with them i mean catholicism doesn't
believe
in a millennium
post
this earthly existence
he they believe in a millennialism when
the church will rule for a thousand
years
well good luck for them but these even
the other christian denominations have
the same
view they have kingdom theology
so if you have kingdom theology why
would you wait for the coming of christ
and the other interesting thing is
the other denominations they believe in
the rapture
and the rest will still be down here
but that's not biblical either
so if you are drunk with this
with this wine
why would you be watching
for the coming of the lord you would be
saying you know the lord delays he's
coming he's not coming for another 100
years 200 years a thousand years 2 000
years we have lots of time
martin would you be anxious
and
praying earnestly to be counted worthy
to stand before the son of man
if you have no concept of his soon
coming
i i can't see that you will all right
now why would you want to call yourself
an adventist
what does advent mean
second coming or the coming of the lord
all right that's the great hope right
why would you want to delay it
doesn't make any sense no i don't think
they should call themselves adventists
i don't know what we shall call them
they should they must think of another
name but that one certainly doesn't fit
so the lord of that servant shall come
in a day when he looketh not for him
because he's not watching in an hour
that he's not aware of because he wasn't
watching
at the sad state is that
there's a lot if we take just the ten
virgins the sleeping virgins yes
we've got a parallel there as well with
this
can you be a happy go lucky general
member in the church not worrying about
the coming of the lord and carrying on
yes you can can you be a theologian in
that same category yes we have them all
but the bottom line is
watch
so let's take a quote from the spirit of
prophecy counsels for the church
the danger of thinking christ's coming
is delayed
that evil servant who says in his heart
my lord delays his coming
profess to be waiting for christ he was
a servant outwardly devoted to the
service of god
while at heart he had yielded to satan
that's pretty strong language
but it comes back to what the bible says
if you're not for god you're against him
that is the way there's no sitting on
the fence no and jesus said watch and
these people say you're watching in the
wrong place we're not worried about this
he does not like the scoffer openly deny
the truth but reveals in his life the
sentiment of the heart that the lord's
coming is delayed
presumption renders him careless of
eternal interests he accepts the world's
maxims
and conforms to its customs and
practices now martin
i don't want to say too much
but have we experienced even within our
own ranks
a conformity to customs and practices of
the world not only in terms of worship
style but also in terms of
specific legislations that have been
introduced in the world of late has
there been coercion
in particular directions
why
because you have accepted the world's
maxims and conformed to its customs and
practices
if you take any issue climate change
are there within the our ranks people
that are on that bandwagon and want to
save the world from this calamity yes
are we
approaching the time of the second
coming oh for sure
and this are we going to save the planet
for another million years because we are
going to stop exuding carbon dioxide
and asphyxiate ourselves no
anything that god created the natural
is now taboo
all right so once you start thinking
like the world
then
you will accept the world's maxims
and then you will conform to its customs
and practices
but if you are watching for the signs of
the times
if you have read
that satan
messes with the climate
have we read those statements in the
past many times
that he
controls the elements of nature and
brings about the storms that sweep away
the harvests and the houses
we shout climate change
oh no the world chants climate change
and the wicked servant shouts climate
change
when in actual fact it's the outworking
of darker elements
in the time of job was it climate change
that swept away
the houses of his children and the
harvests
no definitely not
and that's a problem because you shift
like you say
your whole outs
look on how what's actually the truth
because the watchmen sit on the wall and
the evil
servant sits on the fence
that's right he sits on the fence and
and wants to be able to play his game
however the chips might fall
dangerous thing because once you
want to stand for something like the
needle to the pole
that's no time to sit on the fence the
bible calls that lukewarm and lukewarm
will be spat
out
that brings me to another thing that
just popped up in my mind
that there were even people that said
you said
that
we should stay in that laodicean state
our church
that's very interesting can you just
perhaps clear up and make that also
clear again
the church is in the loudest in
state
if you remain in that state you will be
lost that's it
now will the whole church climb out of
the loaded sea and state unfortunately
not no
but i am
in the world but not of the world i am
in the church but i do not have to be of
the loudest state to be in the church
it might be a general trend within the
church
but if i remain in that state i will be
lost
thank you
so
why would you want to
conform to these practices selfishness
worldly pride
ambitions
predominate you don't want to appear
different
but we are supposed to be a peculiar
people
we are supposed to be
a people
that are
watched not only by the world
but even by the angelic host
we are spectacle or a showcase to the
universe correct
fearing that his brethren might stand
higher than himself he begins to
disparage their efforts and impugn their
motives so let's say you are a
prominent liberal within the church
maybe even in leadership
and
these watchmen
are saying the opposite to what you are
saying
and your position
and your ambition in your position
moves you motivates you
to elevate your position over that of
the watchman then the only thing that is
available to you is ridicule
because you have to get rid of what the
watchman says in order to look prominent
yourself
no it can't work so must that put you
off from being a watchman no
no that must establish you no it is one
of the signs of the times yeah
because the church is going to go in
that direction
so if it doesn't go in that direction
then the bible is wrong then the church
is not lukewarm but hot
but it's not it's lukewarm so the when
you're watching me on the wall expect
this to happen so where does he start
doing this wicked servant he starts
smiting his fellow servants
he starts writing his little articles in
his little papers
and smites his fellow servant or they do
their videos on youtube
they do that too yes
as he alienates himself from the people
of god he unites more and more with the
ungodly
there are people that actually see it in
the paper light
and when the papal system makes a move
that appears right to them
they swallow the other morsels as well
he is found eating and drinking with a
drunkard joining with the wildlings and
partaking of their spirit
thus he is lulled into a carnal security
and overcomes by forgetfulness
indifference and sloth
the modern if you are not a watchman
if you are not watching you are a wicked
servant
you will say the lord delays his coming
you will be forgetful of what is being
taught
you will become indifferent
and you will become slothful
and the slothful will also be that is
that
your evangelizing yes
it will be
set a side there's lots of time there's
no need for urgency here in fact you've
become a servant of satan and you do not
know it
it's like
the church and the time of jesus they
had become servants of satan
they were so rigid in keeping the law
that they were willing to murder in
order to keep it which was breaking the
law yeah
not only in the sight in the in the case
of jesus
but in all the martyrs whether we're
talking about stephen whether we're
talking about paul
they
contrived a plot
not to eat or drink
until they had killed him
and they called that righteousness
that is sad and in for but unfortunately
that also applies to the end at with us
correct people think that they're doing
god's service by getting rid of those
that have been the watchmen
okay so let's move on to another
question
can you help me understand if aaron's
rod and the jar of mana were in the ark
of the covenant
all right
so originally martin
the ark of the covenant contained
the tables of stone
that's what they contained the law of
god
the condemnation of the law
was shielded by the mercy seat
the why was the pot of manna
placed in the ark and why was aaron's
rod placed in the ark
now both of them are symbols of the
priestly ministry
the manna is
a symbol of the word that came down and
became flesh
that's why jesus said you must eat and
drink
the body and the blood
of christ
so
basically the manna is the symbol of
jesus christ the living word
and aaron's rod that budded is a
fascinating story because there were
claims that others
should be the priest and not just aaron
and so the question was settled by them
putting their rods down
and the other rods never budded
but aaron's rod not only butted it
produced flowers and fruit
that's very interesting and it was
placed inside the ark of the covenant
as a reminder of an eternal priesthood
pointing to christ
so the ark of the covenant
essentially was to contain the law
but these two other symbols were added
the part of manner
and this part of manner
never went rotten yeah manna only lasted
for one day
except
on the sabbath day
it was collected on the friday it lasted
throughout the sabbath
if
any other day that was attempted worms
would come into it
but not there so this was
a symbol of the eternal word
that would always be there to feed
humanity in a spiritual sense
so it's fitting that they were in the
ark of the covenant but they were not
always retained there
as far as my understanding goes all
right so let's read one kings eight
verse nine there was nothing in the ark
save the two tables of stone
which
moses put there at horeb when the lord
made a covenant with the children of
israel when they came out of the land of
egypt so that was the original position
the ark of the covenant contained the
law of god which is a transcript of the
character of god
it was holy it had to be treated in a
very specific way
anybody just opened that lid they would
be
dead instantly as even as they
even if they just touched it
like straightening it out when the oxen
stumbled they had no right to put it on
on a cot because that was not according
to the instruction of god but of course
the philistines weren't punished because
they had no such knowledge so god
overlooked their ignorance but he did
not overlook the ignorance when it came
to the israelites
so later when we read in hebrews 9 4 and
the ark of the covenant overlaid around
about with gold where in was the golden
pot that had the manna
and aaron's rod that budded and the
tables of the covenant
that was all placed within the ark with
india and as we have stated it is
fitting
because it refers to the character of
god he is the living word jesus christ
is the living word
and he is the eternal high priest
that brings forth
the fruits of righteousness
so where is the ark we don't know where
it is it is secluded it was hidden
before nebuchadnezzar destroyed the
temple
so
the temple after that was devoid of this
piece of furniture
but it doesn't get rid of the symbolism
no so some people and this person also
mentions it here um
might have thought
by the statement in hebrews that it was
meant that these items were in the most
holy place and not within the ark but
i'm sure out of this
reading that we've just done we're in
the golden pot and man they were within
the ark yes
now the earthly of course was a copy of
the heavenly
so here's a statement in early writings
which might clarify the issue
jesus stood by the ark and as the saints
prayers came up to him
the incense in the censer would smoke
and he would offer up their prayers with
the smoke of the incense to his father
this is now the golden altar of incense
yes and this is now happening in heaven
yes
and the golden altar was in the holy
but the smoke ascended over the curtain
onto the ark of the covenant
in the ark was the golden pot of manna
aaron's rod that buttered and the tables
of stone which folded together like a
book
jesus opened them and saw the ten
commandments written on them with the
finger of god on one table were four
and on the other six
the four on the first table shown
brighter than the other six
now there's been a lot of criticism over
this statement
but obviously it must be so because the
first four referred to god
and that must be brighter
than the ones that refer to humanity
right
the four on the first table shown
brighter than the other six but the
fourth
the sabbath commandment shone above them
all
now that one again is criticized like
crazy that statement but let's just look
at the logic
the first commandment is a statement of
fact
i am the lord your god
i'm the one who took you out of egypt
you shall have no other gods besides me
it's a statement of fact
it's also a very specific
deity that is identified
the one that took the israelites out of
egypt
it leaves no room for other deities
therefore echemenism
cannot work because you are not dealing
with this particular deity in many other
cases right
the second commandment
has to do with
how you worship him
not through idolatry
because you cannot represent him by
things made of wooden stone
you can only
see his character by your association
with him
so it is a
a command determining your mode of
worship
right yes
the third one has to do with reverence
how do you approach this deity not
blaspheming his name not using his name
in vain not misrepresenting him
not misrepresenting his character you
can't call yourself a christian
and then misrepresent his character
in that form
the fourth commandment
deals with the acknowledgement of his
absolute authority
so the fourth one is the one that gives
validity to the entire law
because he commands it because he's the
creator he's the king of the universe
and he calls it his sign he's symbol of
authority
now obviously
a law
can only be
validated if it has authority behind it
if you
that's a good point because if you've
got
me writing a law for the country will
anybody listen to me i don't think so
but if the president of the country does
it he has authority behind him he can
actually enforce it right
same with god he will enforce it
so the fourth one
giving authority to the entire law must
shine brighter than the rest
because if you had signed it it wouldn't
be brighter
even if the president of the united
states signed it it wouldn't give it
more authority
god signed it
that's it okay
and it also puts it in sequence
once you do the fourth that you will do
the the other three of the first table
and once you've got this relationship
sorted out
the other six
will follow in sequence automatically
once you've once you accept the
authority
all the others become
it's axiomatic it has to be it has to be
that way
so the holy sabbath looked glorious a
helio of glory was all around it i saw
that the sabbath commandment was not
nailed to the cross
if it was the other nine commandments
were and we are at liberty to break them
all
as well as to break the forth i saw that
god did not change the sabbath for he
never changes but the pope had changed
it from the seventh to the first day of
the week
for he was to change times and laws
that's pretty straightforward
i think uh i can conquer with every
single statement on
in this quote
i think this also makes it clear that
aaron's rod
and the pot of manna were in the outside
of the ark okay now why did we
use this question in the first place
because we have another issue which we
addressed in one of our previous
discussions
and
that is the the issue of the greatest
commandment the greatest commandment
what is the greatest commandment you
shall love the lord your god
now if you love the lord your god
that means that you have a relationship
with him
right exactly and
it also means that you acknowledge his
authority
and that you understand his authority
and accept his authority and are willing
to perform the duties prescribed
right that's it
so
when it comes to the three angels
messages
the question
was to which one of the two tables
are the three angels messages referring
to
now martin this is interesting and
i think it's a very very important
question
the three angels messages
i think we should go there i mean we've
been there so often let's go there again
it's in revelation
chapter 14.
the three angels messages start in verse
6 of chapter 14 and if you have one of
those bibles with the bold face to tell
you where the beginning of a paragraph
is you will see that verse 6 is
highlighted
and it says and i saw another angel fly
in the midst of heaven having the
everlasting gospel
to preach unto them that dwell on the
earth
and to every nation kindred and tongue
and people
now the gospel is of course the gospel
of salvation that's the good news of
salvation in jesus christ
and it is an everlasting gospel it's one
that cannot be changed it cannot be
altered
it has to be the same from the time of
adam
to the last person on earth yeah
exactly okay
so how was adam saved according to this
gospel
by the blood of the lamb
how was he clothed because he was naked
christ's righteousness
he wore the coat of the lamb which
represented christ and his righteousness
so adam and eve were saved by the
righteousness of christ
where they excluded from the garden
because of transgression of the law yes
so was there a law
definitely there had to be a law right
or else they couldn't have been excluded
okay so this gospel has never changed
as rome changed the gospel yes
completely
even removed the atonement
right and changed the day of worship
changed the entire law of god
abbreviated where they thought it
essential to abbreviate it so that they
could retain the power rather than god
right
and
i think that their lackeys
are doing the same thing
the tenth commandment for example says
that you may not covet your neighbor's
goods
which implies that the neighbor has
goods yes but the economic forum the
world economic forum says you will own
nothing and be happy exactly so it's a
direct
opposing the tenth commandment it's
opposing the tenth commandment
so can you happily go along with the
ideologies of the world economic forum
no no no matter
how many schwabs there are
you cannot go along with it yeah and if
you take this
that all these laws that they or this
great reset
everything that's happening i think we
are trying to show as well to people
that they are implementing it all right
okay so there's an everlasting gospel it
has never been changed the law has
always been linked
to the plan of salvation
in fact there would be no need of a plan
of salvation if there were no law
because without a law there's no
transgression if there's no
transgression there's no condemnation
without condemnation you don't need a
savior
right it's very logical so if there is a
savior and if he died
then it means that the law could not be
compromised and the price for the
transgression had to be paid that
doesn't get rid of the law
it just pays the price for the
transgression of the law
and you can appropriate the
righteousness of christ
and that is your only means of salvation
if you remove that from the equation
like rome has done
you have destroyed the everlasting
gospel and whatever morsel
of it that you swallow
makes you a transgressor together with
rome
so if you take part
in a universal eucharistic celebration
you are eating
idolatry
that is precisely what happens okay so
there's an everlasting gospel and the
issue has to be set straight by the
by
the first angel's message
and it has to be preached to everyone on
earth and to every nation kindred and
tongue and people
that means even those that are governed
by other religious forms have to hear
this message whether they like it or not
that's it
whether they
accept or forbear that's not your
problem you have to preach it
now what does this angel say
he says with a loud voice fear god
martin if you say fear god and give
glory to him
then which commandments are entailed in
in that well okay actually the first
four
okay all right so you will have no other
gods beside him
you will certainly not practice idolatry
you won't take past in a universal
eucharistic celebration for example
moreover you will not use his name in
vain
and because he said you must keep the
sabbath you will keep the sabbath right
then it says for the hour of his
judgment has come
now judgment obviously needs a standard
of judgment yes what is that the law the
law
and we've just discussed the law all
right but together with the law there
was a pot of manna and there was aaron's
rod that
blossomed and bore fruit right
so
it refers to the
high priestly ministry of jesus christ
so this is a highly christocentric
religion
for the hour of his judgment has come
there's a standard of judgment which is
the law therefore
worship him
that made the heavens the earth and the
sea and the fountains of water in which
commandment do we find that statement
the fourth commandment
okay
so only in the fourth commandment
do you read the statement
heaven
and earth the sea
and the fountains of water it is in the
commandment of authority
whose authority do you exactly
so the first angels messages
embraces
all four
on the first
table of stone
there's nothing about the other six
this is about
the key word there is
worship
in other words who do you acknowledge as
your god
now
if your god says to you i have a sign
and that is
the sabbath
did he say it is a sign between me and
the children of israel forever yes he
did all right here's my sign that you
acknowledge
that i am the lord that sanctifies you
ezekiel says that right
i am the lord that sanctifies you
then keep the sabbath verily my sabbath
you shall keep
right
and you're acknowledging him that he is
your creator
and that he is your redeemer because
it's going to sanctify you
and another power comes and says
is not your redeemer we don't believe in
the atonement
jesus never died for you
he died because he was obedient but he
didn't die for you you have to stand for
your own sins
and we will provide the means for your
sanctification we will give you
sacraments and we if you fall short will
give from our treasury of merit towards
you you are saved by our actions
and i want you to acknowledge it by
accepting my mark my sign of authority
sunday
well now you have two authorities to
listen to
which one are you going to accept
the one that you choose to accept is
going to determine
that
statement that we read but what's going
to happen to you when you meet god okay
so
if i acknowledge
god's ownership of me through
creation and redemption
and he says to me the sign that you have
done this
is the sabbath
and the pope says no no no you're not
saved this way you save this way i have
another gospel for you and the sign that
you acknowledge my authority because
rome says that the keeping of sunday by
the protestant is an acknowledgement of
the authority of rome in spite of their
teacher the bible
which they actually are correct in
stating that yes they are correct in
that but it is arrogance of the highest
order
therefore my decision is i will not obey
the authority
because it has to do with worship
so
the issue of the first angel's
message is
worship
and it's only in the first four
commandments and specifically the fourth
let's continue
again it is boldface it is another
paragraph it stands by itself the second
angel's message because
verse nine is again boldface in other
words it's again a standalone paragraph
and it's a little bit longer
but
verse 8
second angel's message and they followed
another angel saying babylon has fallen
his fallen the great city because she
made all the nations drink of the wine
of the wrath of her fornication
the sad point is
that in this issue of worship
the churches would rather follow the
dictates of rome
because on her forehead is written
babylon
the mother
of harlots
now she's the mother but she has
children
and they are also harlots
in other words they have transgressed
and gone the way of apostasy they have
followed the mother
rather
than their teacher which happens to be
the bible right
so the second angel's message
has to do with worship
because babylon
the mother of harlots
has made them drink of the false wine
the false gospel of salvation
and has induced the mindset in them
that they would rather follow
her
than their preferred teacher the bible
right
okay
so if it's an issue of worship
this is just an antithesis to the first
one the first one says
how it should be done
the second one says babylon refuses to
do it yeah
and it also made other nations or other
people drink of that same
apostasy not worshiping okay so she
doesn't want to sin by herself
she induces sin in all the others and
anybody who sits at her table imbibing
this wine
in whatever shape or form it comes
and if it is even obliquely
geared
towards making her mark of authority
prominent like climate change issues for
example then you are partaking of this
wine
it's deceptive wine but it has to do
with worship
definitely the first one the everlasting
gospel
worship him were made
they're saying no
follow our dictates
then comes the third one
and the third angel followed them saying
with a loud voice if any man worshipped
the beast
stop right there worship who is the
beast
catholicism yeah
the reformers made it quite clear
because all the attributes of the beast
are listed in revelation chapter 13
and they are identical to the attributes
of daniel chapter 7's little horn
and that is the papacy because no other
organization fits all those criteria
okay
so again the issue if any man worship
the beast
worship god said the first angel
worship god it's an issue of worship
first table or second table first table
first table
so are you meaning to tell me martin
that the entire three angels message
relate to the first table of the law
exactly that's 100 what it
entails okay
so you worship the beast if you worship
catholicism
or if you worship his image
now we read about the image in
revelation chapter 13
because protestant america sets up an
image
an image looks like the original
the original was church and stayed
together
now there's a movement in the united
states to amend the constitution
so that the issue of the separation of
church and state becomes clear
that that is not
the intent according to them
of the founding fathers
all right
so they want to change
the issues so that they
can become like the first beast that
controlled the state
so church and state coming together
and the church
controlling the state
yielding the spiritual sword which rome
claims
in order to
enact legislation
that favors
the first beast and like we've shown the
danger
in this
is that most of it will be
godly and
those legislations we will agree with it
in many cases in many cases we will
agree with them
but
can you
legislate morality no because then
you're back at the waste of free choice
all right now here's another question
even if you do legislate
you might alter behavior
but you can never change the heart
so
coercion
in any form
doesn't change the heart
so we had this discussion before
if you are inclined to sin
and there is legislation against that
particular
sin
then it means that you will just do it
in darkness exactly in your mind even
all right so when they prohibited in the
past the selling of alcohol in the
united states
which business flourished the most
the moonshine the moonshine business
so you cannot legislate morality but if
you change the heart yeah
and worship god that's it and give glory
to him
so
it comes back to if
why the first four
commandments the first table because if
that
relationship is right
the others that morality will follow in
the last segment it'll come right but it
will not only come right in action
it'll come right in the heart so your
mind will also be
fit for it babylon
can
never
achieve what the gospel achieves
babylon can only change behavior
it cannot
change the heart
so the third angel's message
he follows and he says it says with a
loud voice if any man worship the beast
if any man
obeys catholicism
because the bible says
he whom you obey his servant you have
become
catholicism and in the image of the
beast
protestantism
doing the bidding
of rome and becoming like it an
oppressive power to legislate morality
and receive his mark
now
he has told us what his mark is
sunday is my mark of authority i said
why does protestantism deny it i don't
know
because i think that part is still
they're drunk with
babylonian wine
and if they choose to remain drunk
it is because they do not want to change
they are complacent
and where is this mark received either
in your cognitive capacity you actually
convince that ram is right
or in your hand you are a conformist and
are doing as you are told to stay out of
trouble that's it
so i
yeah i don't think they're right in this
i actually think that we act but i'm not
gonna go to jail so i'll do it yeah so
i'll do it
okay
so cognitively you are convinced by this
mark of the beast
or
in your behavior
you are modified
to conform to the mark of the beast
in both cases you are condemned
the same shall drink of the wine of the
wrath of god which is poured out without
mixture into the cup of his indignation
so
god talks about a time when he will
press the wine press
and it will come up to the girdle of the
horse that he is riding
he's going to press the wine press alone
and the wrath of god is going to be
poured up on the transgressors of his
law and on those that divert worship
away from the real way
to the false word
and he shall be tormented with fire and
brimstone in the present of the holy
angels and in the presence of the lord
and that is
the fire that comes down
from heaven the presence of the lamb
and the smoke of their torment ascends
up forever and ever and they have no
rest day or night
who worship the beast and his image and
whosoever receives the mark of his name
now some people think that the torment
will go on forever and ever but we have
such clear statements that say they will
consume into smoke
they will be as though they never were
it's the consequences but there's an
interesting little word in this verse
that they have no rest
now which commandment is associated with
rest martin the fourth commandment it
comes back to it all the time right
it's the commandment of rest
and hebrews says
that you will not enter into the rest
if you enter in by your own works
you have to go in by the righteousness
of christ now babylon
can address
no it cannot rest
because it enters by its own works
it's like we've mentioned in the
previous one they've taken out the
commandments and they've even changed
one for themselves yes but that
relationship that
covering
mercy seat
is gone if you so how many indications
do we have in these few verses of the
relevance of the sabbath
every one
it's there right you cannot it's the
issue why is it so important
because it's the
showing the authority of god it it
shines brighter
than the others that's right and if you
acknowledge his authority
then you are also
inclined to worship him according to his
dictates because otherwise you wouldn't
acknowledge his authority
it's as simple as that it all falls into
sequence if you do this this will happen
and so forth so who doesn't find rest
day nor night
those who worship the beast in other
words obey the dictates of catholicism
his image fallen protestantism united
with the secular world to enforce the
doctrines of whom the first beast
martin do we see that in the united
states of america you know what the
problem is you actually see it on both
side of the political spectrum okay now
the politicians
that are
uh trying to enforce this change in the
constitution
uh that even stood for president in the
past the ones that said that
they want to throw up when they listen
to kennedy's speech
so many years ago 2012 i had a lecture
where i showed rick santorum who said
that he wanted to throw up
when he listened to kennedy's speech on
the separation of church and state
and
it just showed
how zealous they were
to
bring about the union of church and
state and if i remember correctly in
that lecture
i stated that
he was a member of opus dei okay
now opus dei is a group of people that
remind themselves of their obligation to
rome
by wearing restrictive bands that will
create pain on occasion
but
be that as it may
there is this move
to enforce people
views because
look at the morality in the world
it's gone down the tubes we need the
church and protestant america is going
to reach across the gulf and grab the
hand of rome and they will enforce
their legislation and one of them here
has to do with the commandment of rest
do not accept the mark of the beast and
rome has identified its mark
so
here is the patience of the saints
here are they that keep the commandments
of god and the faith of jesus
it is quite clear that the entire three
angels message deal with worship
exactly now the second table
is there any worship in it can you
worship your father and your mother no
no no you can honor them yes but you
cannot worship
them you will worship the lord your god
alone worship is part of the first table
so why will humanity eventually be
largely rejected
because they did not
keep
or love or worship
the lord according to the first table in
other words they didn't keep the first
great commandment
you shall love the lord your god with
all your heart and with all your soul
and with all your mind
and your neighbor as yourself
so the first great commandment as we
discussed it last time
is the issue of revelation chapter 14.
it is the final call to worship
because if you're going to spend
eternity with god in heaven
you better make sure you have the right
god
that's 100 the thing
and which one is that it's the one that
created you
[Music]
it's also the one that redeemed you
right i'm your redeemer that's why
there's a part of manna that's why
there's a staff of aaron that buttered
in that ark of the covenant
that is why
there are
two tables the one shines brighter than
the other and the fourth commandment
which is the commandment of authority
shines more than any of them and if you
violate it you are violating
the very precepts of which god you are
honoring and worshiping
and you cannot go to heaven
to spend eternity with someone
that you have directly through your
action rejected here on earth
simple as that
therefore you will be eternally lost if
you do not do that
so
to which one of the two tables are the
three angels messages referring to
the first table the first table let's
close with prayer thank you so much
heavenly father
the issue is an issue of worship
and i for one lord i'm grateful that i
in my darkness and in my atheism of the
past
discovered the god that is worthy of
worship worthy is the lamb
for he has paid the price
and has
enabled redemption
and is prepared to cover
his children with his righteousness
and that cloak of righteousness
is
the ticket
the passport
to eternity
and we need to acknowledge it by
acknowledging
the authority of the one that hands us
the passport
help humanity
to make the right choice is my prayer in
jesus name amen
[Music]
you